you
for any problem you work on this some
moment where this sort of maybe it's a
model that no one else cares about where
it sort of all fit together and I found
some simple way of doing something
there's also the models that people have
heard about some such as the models
about extra dimensions something else
that we did having to do with a
different way of communicating
supersymmetry breaking there were a lot
of Eureka moments in in that making it
work out and the fact that we could all
tied together so it's hard for me to
pull this out because a lot of the time
when you're working on something that
there's that one thing that you get
excited about
I think one thing that surprised us
ramen and I when we were working
together was this existence of the
possibility of the existence of an
infinite extra dimension you know people
who had actually thought there were
theorems that you couldn't have and if
an extra dimension that gravity would
just look wrong that there was no
consistent way to do it and it was
really interesting because we came
across this by work really following the
consequence of our equations to the end
and there was just no mistaking that it
was allowing the possibility of an extra
dimension it was interesting to go back
and see what assumptions have been made
that made us think or made other people
think that it wasn't possible and just
to see how the theory was almost smarter
than we were and worked it out that was
kind of fun